you're watching screen junkie central
this episode is brought to you by mafia
3 family is who you die for
what's going on everybody Comic Con 2016
I'm here suicide squads here The Joker's
here let's do this I'm gonna hurt you
really really bad I'm kind of scared
let's go
can you just stand right there for a
second okay
go I am here with star-lord let me ask
you this what are some of the songs that
are gonna be on the awesome mix vol 2
well it wouldn't be complete without
some Nickelback so no you just ruined
guardians of the galaxy for me I'm
standing here with uh
what character are you hmm
what do you do in your real life when
you're not dressed as this character I'm
an application analyst do the folks at
the old application analysts office know
that you dress up like this the drew dot
oMG who are you wearing
ah Deadpool Bjork Deadpool that's
amazing are you guys excited to be the
only Deadpool's
at 2016 San Diego comic-con you know
it's good to just have a really original
idea what Deadpool are you I just got
done with the shower
I am Deadpool senpai hi girls faith pool
uh Deadpool jr. I'm residing on a fancy
you know night out on the town kind of
smooth smooth wanna yes
fancy smooth night on the town Deadpool
did you say to yourself I'm gonna wear
the weakest Deadpool cosplay of all time
today no I did not
that's tomorrow so I want to film a
Canadian tourism commercial with the
three greatest Canadians of all time
Terrance and Phillip and Deadpool okay
on the count of three say visit Canada
one two three visit Canada can I sign
your cast yes please say that would be
awesome
I wrote Hal Rudnick bye-bye
thank you you're pretty cool obviously
I'm standing in front of a statue of
Superman who is very clearly doing an
interpretive dance an ode to comic-con
to the tune of dance of the sugarplum
fairy OMG tell me who are you wearing
Inspector Gadget what do you do in real
life I um I'm a foreclosure special
specialist your foreclosure specialist
jeez would you ever show up in a whacky
outfit being like hey you're out of your
house no you look like such a fun guy
but what a depressing job
I'm here with Frodo Baggins and the
resemblance to Elijah Wood is striking
are you afraid that you're going to get
mobbed I hope I do that'd be fantastic
oh so you want to angle this to get
groupies is that what you're saying for
sure are the feet a deal breaker
they're pretty bad right now yeah are
those things comfortable to walk in not
at all Fred I respect like you're an
old-timey guy but you're walking around
comic-con in bare feet you're not afraid
of the disgusting fungus no I'm not what
what's gonna happen when you have to go
into men's room ah yeah that's gross you
are the Droid I'm looking for a bee boop
beep oh that's a great r2d2 impression
joke are any predictions on how the
movies to oh I just got kissed by Joker
what is your favorite Star Wars movie Oh
Revenge of the fist so you like that
better than Empire Strikes Back that was
good too all of them without Jar Jar
Binks
I hold your Jar Jar you don't like Jar
Jar I am here with the one the only the
Mandarin how's it going Mandarin
wonderful wonderful so you got some cool
bling bling right there show it off yeah
I made these out of plexiglass old
pieces of jewelry and uh silver spoons I
have two schools of thought about that
one it is damn impressive too you've got
a lot of time on your hands he's got a
hole right here like a hole was shot
through him and he's got a camera behind
him
what's up comic-con scream John
whoo Mass Effect I'm coming through you
you know I think I wandered a little far
from San Diego and I've wound up in
South Park look guys I'm pretending to
interview a wooden statue how funny is
that well I'm finally doing what so many
commenters have told me to do over the
years I've gone to hell all right you've
heard of Wolverine you've heard of old
man Logan but right here we got who are
you
gibbering jouvert een Wow are you
jouvert eenz arch enemy probably if I
ever meet any no look I am Mazel Tov all
right I am here with the pinball wizard
and you are by far the best cosplay of a
whose song that I've seen all day there
was a very good teenage wasteland cap
how do you feel about how the Civil War
went down well some people make mistakes
but unfortunately sometimes we have to
do things that sacrifice others for the
good of the world
Bucky that was a that was a tough go for
you how do you feel about how the Civil
War went down I feel [ __ ] responsible
I was framed
Captain America thank you for talking to
me you very much
Bucky thank you for talking to me thanks
for having me woman who played Captain
America and Bucky thank you for talking
to me thank you so much you know every
time you think that you've seen
everything that comic-con possibly has
to offer something surprises you Elvis
on stilts with a shark coming through
them thank you very much
since you're wearing Star Wars cosplay
and you are an actual flight attendant
correct would you please give us a
flight safety speech for flying on the
Millennium Falcon uh let you can do it I
believe in you use the Force tell us who
your character is
okay I'm dude Vader I survived the
battle with my son I decided to heck
with the dark side I'm going picking out
on the beach and become dude Vader I
excited about homecoming actually more
excited about prom
oh yeah ha ha good one Spidey dude Bader
you got any of that Humboldt push I
can't tell you
I mean lucasfilm's is up there in
Northern California yes I know but
Disney is down in Southern California oh
that's true
ha ha the good folks at Disney don't
want dude Vader smoking any weed it
looks like you decapitated a turtle yes
Donatello's dead so did you come to
comic-con to ruin childhoods who
received the blunt end of Lucille
I never tale Oh negan you're so coy how
are you in there
unbury accustomed to my food thank you
deep in character I love it let's have a
moment of silence for this cosplay that
has that is no more you know what should
I put it on you guys should I put on
this disgusting thing oh there's a
strange odor in here who knows who wore
this I'm probably gonna get head lice
now okay I'm taking this off thank you
for watching this is Al Rudnick signing
off from screen junkies at gob of God
they be up on Twitter bye-bye I died
thanks again to mafia 3 for sponsoring
this episode and fear not honest
trailers fans you are still getting your
fix this we'd come back Thursday for an
epic trailer the action franchise that's
about to get reborn get it reborn we're
doing the Bourne trilogy ok
on Thursday be there